The Joe Rogan Experience they found some
of those teeth and shipments of dragon
bones oh what the [ __ ] were dragons what
is that I'm sure they were selling them
as dragon bones yeah but like I wonder
what those were probably dinosaurs
dragon bones they collected 47 teeth
among shipments of in quotes dragon
bones speaking of dragon bones anybody
like heard from Charlie Sheen lately
dragon bones my friends saw him at a
restaurant one time look at the [ __ ] out
here and he takes a video he goes look
he eats because he's just the guy's
going like this I'm just like just
imagine that that that guy had achieved
like this enormous oh here goes from
baller to squalor Charlie Sheen moves
into modest Malibu apartment after he
was forced to live with his dad 80 and
Mom 76. oh it is man I heard he lost all
his teeth it hurts oh he's I know he's
unwell so I guess if uh yeah yeah well
that's what becomes see if you can find
the most current photo of Charlie Sheen
I figured that would have had it I
remember when like people were using
tiger blood and that wasn't that long
ago right it was like 15 years ago no
not that long it was ten yeah
and he went off the rails that was a
crazy time but when people found out
that he had HIV that's when they were
like not so funny anymore
and you know it possibly had given it to
other people
not the coolest thing Charlie he was the
guy that was like you remember when he
did that interview where he was like
yeah yeah I'm I [ __ ] smoke crack yeah
I love it I would uh Tiger Blood smoke
grams of it yeah
#winning
did he even use hashtag winning or did
you say winning he used hashtag winning
I don't think it does anymore I mean but
I don't think he said hashtag winning I
think he just said winning yeah winning
and he was he was uh he was half a year
ago Jesus Christ please play that play
that this is give me get some volume
he's doing for Cameo it's a thing
come on is it not working I won't remain
here I will I will remain available if
if you can all agree that uh that that
all the tiger blood and winning and if
we could just kind of just
kind of leave that where it belongs in
the past
um hey this is tough to watch man it's
very difficult it sounds like he doesn't
listen keep going that that that we're
all finding our way through so so if a
message from me can can can brighten the
day of of yourself or or a loved one or
even someone you don't really care about
then uh then I'm then I'm honored to to
offer that so uh
greetings
good people of Planet cameo
it's the sheen
I'm back
whoa that's heavy I remember when he was
doing live performances or he's going
out and he's doing he was selling out
theaters and the first one he did was a
like everybody was excited to see him
but then they realized it was after he
got fired from Two and a Half Men they
realized he really didn't have an act
yet so then he realized like I got to do
something I sold out all these theaters
and now people are going to scream at me
and be mad at me because he was like
[ __ ] you you paid to see me you [ __ ]
losers like that kind of [ __ ] he was
just being defensive right right then he
hired my friend Russell Peters and
Russell Peters took over and was like
interviewing him and then the shows
became actually success because Russell
is very entertaining and what are you
doing Canada represents he says this
wasn't new but uh he blames all of those
fun quotes on uh too much testosterone
cream he was using to try to get his
libido up
Freud Ridge accidental roid rate that's
what tiger blood came from nothing to do
with Coke you know who the by the way do
you know who the last noted celebrity
was to visit to visit Marineland who
Russell Peters oh look let's scroll up
let me see what he looked like back then
no no I'm sorry scroll down the video
like look how good he looks he looked
vibrant it is sad to see where he's gone
in his voice there's just not let me
hear that
that's Michael Strahan is interviewing
us Good Morning America for eight months
now I've been enrolled in an FDA study
for a medication for a drug called
pro140 that's that's in in the late
stages of its of its of its trial run we
are very close to being approved
um and it is not this hideous cocktail
that leads to so many side effects
emotionally and physically
it's one shot a week it's going well and
I I feel like I'm carrying the torch for
a lot of folks out there that are
suffering from the same same thing you
know in all of this that has happened
have there been a silver lining oh yeah
yeah yeah no I mean today I got the dad
was diagnosed I immediately wanted to
eat a bullet can I stop it pause right
there I wouldn't
Michael Strahan is such a stud that his
lisp actually helps him become more
endearing we've never fixed the Gap in
his teeth yeah but it's also like it's
like such a [ __ ] Alpha such a beast
of a man such a manly man he invites you
to criticize it go ahead but when he has
a little list be like I like you a
little bit more it's a little bit a
little bit easier to deal with the fact
that you're a superhuman but I think
that he was talking about HIV yeah the
next one he was yeah I want to go way
back see this was what year was this
three years ago Christ he looks so much
better three years ago
what is going on man
that's a it's a really sad thing to see
because you know he he was I mean he
captivated the world for a while I get
it but it's so sad to see you know
there's something about someone who
becomes uh humble later and I mean
there's a level of humility that is
evident in that video where we watch
that he's he's trying to give him some
Cameo orders like it was a dude that was
also who was embracing being like uh
shamed he was like yeah I smell crack
yeah I I eat like I pay hookers to leave
like he was he had all this wildness to
like the way he was accepting this
shifts the Defiance people were like
yeah because people were tired of people
being like they're being humbled by this
and goes back to the genuine and the
honesty factor I mean is there anything
more honesty than admitting your uh drug
addictions there was a little bit it was
that but it was also that he used to be
Charlie Sheen he was Charlie Sheen from
major league and platoon and he was a
massive movie star and then all of a
sudden here he is on television talking
about smoking crack
he had tiger blood
he was a giant uh conspiracy theorist
for a while too remember he wrote a
letter to Obama uh demanding that Obama
released the truth about 9 11.
do you remember that Jeremy no I was
just about to ask you where what I
couldn't remember where this all started
the Charlie Sheen stuff you know like
where where did that first hit was he
live streaming on something or we got
fired
from uh it was the firing that's yeah
that's what propelled it he got fired
from Two and a Half Men and then he went
off on he started calling the the guy by
his uh his proper Jewish name so it
started off as he started and then he
went off who do you call oh
[Laughter]
Alex Jones uh called me once he goes Hey
Joe someone wants to talk to you and he
puts me on the phone with um Gary Busey
oh [ __ ] post motorcycle accident and
Carrie Gary Busey was I mean it was
literally like I was the the beneficiary
of uh this long rant I go hey man what's
up and I was like Hey Joe want to talk
to you about the universe and life and
expanding Consciousness and all these
different things that are happening to
you right now and this is all and Gary
Busey like just talked at me for a few
minutes and then gave the phone back to
Alex and I go what the [ __ ] was that
I'll call you later man catch new
episodes of The Joe Rogan Experience for
free only on Spotify watch back catalog
JRE videos on Spotify including Clips
easily seamlessly switch between video
and audio experience on Spotify you can
listen to the JRE in the background
while using other apps and can download
episodes to save on data cost all for
free Spotify is absolutely free you
don't have to have a premium account to
watch new JRE episodes you just need to
search for the JRE on your Spotify app
go to Spotify now to get this full
episode of The Joe Rogan Experience